Oh [inaudible]
thank you guys for that.
Well,
we've got a standing ovation before we do anything.
This is the way it's supposed to be these days.
The,
but I'm having a very strange week because this is my third event in a row,
uh,
through turning point and today partly with the Iron Ran Institute.
I was at Umass on Monday and it was a great event,
totally respectful and find challenging questions with you guys.
Really just a great exchange of ideas.
Everything that I'm,
that I'm living for at the moment.
And then I was at the University of New Hampshire yesterday.
Well is closer to die yesterday.
[inaudible] is just an absolute circus there.
Uh,
they,
they could not secure a room on campus because of threats.
They moved us,
but 300 students,
they moved us to a 7,500 seat hockey arena,
which was very,
I felt like I was in an episode of Veep,
like a faith background or something.
Um,
and just and screaming and noise makers and all of the things that you guys have
come to know is,
are the things that are shutting down civil discourse.
Uh,
so I hope tonight that we'll,
we'll do it civilly.
We are completely open.
You know,
you're on,
I just discussed.
We will,
we will take any and all questions that you guys have.
We have no plan right now other than to talk it out.
And we agree on some stuff.
Some stuff we disagree on.
You notice he's to my right and I [inaudible] somebody that is to the right of
your,
which now I'm sure Huffington post will call me.
All right.
[inaudible]
you guys see this today?
That'd be fair.
Another one of these hit pieces.
I mean these people are not,
every woman I'm friends with apparently is a Nazi,
which you know,
as a,
as a former member of the IDF on top of that list.
Yeah.
So the point is if they're already protesters here,
he knows how to use a gun.
So be careful.
[inaudible] that's right.
Okay.
So look,
we're going to talk about free markets.
We're going to talk about free speech.
We're going to talk about all the things that I think you guys know that we care
about and we're excited to be here.
So I thought,
first off,
I'm going to throw something kind of interesting at you.
I think something seriously big shifted in the universe last week because of
Kanye west and yeah,
I can't believe I'm saying that [inaudible] I'm more of a Frank Sinatra guy
myself,
but,
but Kanye,
I think by tweeting seven words,
I love the way Candace Owens thinks he offered oxygen to the space that I think
you guys are in.
And he just offered a little space for some other people to think a little bit
differently,
to look a little more critically at some of the issues that we're constantly
talking about.
And he's talking about the individual.
And I,
the second what happened,
I called you and I said,
this is a moment for you guys because Kanye West is talking about the
individual.
Do you think I'm crazy for this?
Uh,
thought,
no,
I think,
I think we are at an interesting moment in time.
I think that,
I actually think that the rest,
and I know,
I know a lot of people disagree with me on this.
I think the left is in retreat.
The left is completely and utterly bankrupt.
And I think New Hampshire was kind of evidence of that.
When you completely bankrupt,
where do you have nothing to say when you have no way to go,
you get noisemakers and you make lots of noise because you can't actually
communicate anymore.
You,
Oh,
you can do is yell and shout and scream and,
and you know,
you're,
you're like a little child because you're completely,
oh,
you haven't said emotion,
you have no mind anymore.
And I really think that the left is,
it's not bad obviously,
because it holds the universities and it holds massive political power still.
But the radical,
the crazy than nutty left is an illustration of that.
This whole thing is in decline.
And even county arrest sees it,
right?
So it's gotten to the point where even some people in pop culture,
uh,
looking at these people and saying,
no,
this,
this is nuts.
There's not,
there's no there,
there,
there's nothing.
There's nothing to hold onto.
There's no values there.
Well,
what are we gonna do with these people?
And I think of all the communities,
the black community should be the one at the forefront of this because they've
been betrayed by the left for generations now.
You know,
since the civil rights movement where yes,
the people stood up for them and marched with them and they deserve all the
credit in the world for doing that.
But since then the war on poverty is not helped them.
All the,
all the whole welfare state,
everything that the government has tried to do to so called the help them has
actually made them worse off and things are worse.
I mean,
she called go,
it's probably the best place in the world right now to see this.
Right.
Because they are worse off than if they'd never been a war on poverty.
If they'd never been,
you know,
certain parts of the Civil Rights Act,
if they've never been this massive attempt somehow to help them,
you know,
to mother government is here to help you.
Right.
That is an awful,
awful sign when somebody says that right to you.
So I think,
I think,
I think the bankrupt,
I think they're out of ideas.
I don't know if you saw Bernie Sanders latest idea is that the governor's
guarantee a job to everybody.
Everybody gets a job like,
like if you can't find a job in the private sector will pay you 15 bucks an
hour.
You can dig ditches and fill them in.
Right.
All Day long.
They can fail,
they can fail.
And this is a serious proposal.
We've got two other Democrats who are running for president who have endorsed
this,
uh,
booker and uh,
not Camilla Harris,
the other woman from New York.
Uh,
the New York senator.
Yeah.
Band.
Right.
And I mean,
this is not easy.
This is did you just announced that they're both running for president
if nobody knew [inaudible] regulations.
Yeah.
Um,
and you know,
that's just so stupid,
right?
That there's nothing,
there's nothing there.
They will question is,
and the real question is,
okay,
so why,
what now?
Right.
What,
what,
what places of what fills the void?
What,
what is,
uh,
what is the alternative to this nuttiness and the idea that Kenya West is
talking about the individual.
I don't know what he means by that.
I see all kinds of tweets by him,
so that makes sense.
Some of them a completely weird.
Um,
but if we can start having a discussion about the individual and what that means
and,
and there may be what individual rights mean and what does individualism mean?
And maybe get him a copy of the fountain head.
Maybe you can read that.
Then it becomes interesting.
Then we're talking about the white kind of things.
If the alternative is,
sorry,
make America great again,
then I'm dubious that,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a make America eat again is a big guy.
I don't know about that.
I think that's just a dent in the habit.
Um,
it looks good though.
I don't know that that's the answer that I liked this idea of talking about the
individual.
Well,
look,
I don't know,
but is
the answer either.
I don't think I look,
as I said in my direct message last week,
I don't know what Kanye is.
Political beliefs are at any moment.
You know,
all of these people that are now worshiping him as a hero,
they most likely will come to regret it when he does something nutty.
But I think he offered oxygen to a space that needed a little oxygen.
You know,
a few of us,
what Eric Weinstein calls the intellectual dark web.
There's been this group of about 20 people kind of trying to just say,
you know what?
Some of us are on the left,
Sam Harris,
some of us are on the right,
Ben Shapiro,
but we're trying to figure out what the answers are without destroying each
other.
And I think Connie offered a little air to that.
But also what's interesting to me is the way the media suddenly just went on a
complete rampage against him.
And,
and the lead moment in Twitter moments was about far right.
Candice Owens far right.
Candice Owens,
who's had dinner at my house with me and my husband.
I mean,
this woman,
she's not a,
she's black by the way.
Not The black people can't be racist,
but they're calling her auntie black the way that they're,
you know,
all these hit pieces that run on Kanye.
Did you guys see the,
the uh,
peace that Maxine waters released a statement about Kanye that he should
basically stay in his lane and,
and,
and it's like this is actually the soft bigotry of low expectations that,
that someone dares to think differently and you say,
no,
we're,
we're going to put them plantation where we've kept you.
Yeah,
exactly.
And this has to be fought.
No,
it definitely,
and I think get also gives it,
you know,
space now to other people in entertainment business that,
as you know,
yeah.
As a silent because they were afraid he end,
he gives space to I think that minority community that feels betrayed by the
left to speak out against it.
And,
and that is,
they've never spoken.
They're not afraid to speak to that point.
I almost every day now I get a direct message on Twitter from somebody that's a
public person,
either a musician or an actor or something telling me that they agree with me,
but they won't say it publicly.
I,
I got something today from somebody in,
in the music.
Is that most of you probably know saying that they were afraid to come out of
the closet,
would you,
I mean that was the phrase they use.
I mean,
were you part of Friends of Abe,
the secret society in Hollywood or we are out,
we spoke about that.
It was before,
right before I moved to La to be a secret society in Los Angeles called friends
of ape,
which was all the directors,
producers,
lighting people,
everybody in the film industry who was left of,
I dunno,
Lennon.
Oh right,
of lenders.
Yeah,
right.
You know,
Of Right.
Of,
of,
of a leftist agenda.
And they used to get together and there was a coffee shop in Hollywood where
like every Wednesday they would get,
you know,
people would get together and wasn't that many of them.
And then once in a while they have these big gatherings and I went once in a
while,
3000 people and a lot of people like I know that guy.
I don't,
you know all these movie stars data you didn't know and they all stay silent
because they were afraid.
We're talking about 3000 people.
Some of them the biggest,
some of the biggest producers in Hollywood,
some of the biggest actors in Hollywood will not come out as being conservatives
are being libertarian or being anything other than the left because they were
afraid for their livelihood.
But that's why I love doing these events with you guys because I truly believe
this,
that we are living in such a unique time right now where everything is up in the
air.
The world truly is yours.
When you get out of college,
like every,
there is nobody that knows what's going to happen tomorrow,
much less than a year from now.
Nobody knows that Trump has,
has just tossed the chess board up.
The pieces are everywhere and you guys were able to make the future.
And the funny thing is when I agreed to do some events with Iran and Ari,
I got people telling me that,
oh you know,
I'm working with these,
these far right maniacs and I've gotten to know you pretty well and,
and you're constantly screaming about freedom.
I mean all you care about,
the only thing you care about is freedom.
So it leads me to this.
I want to do a little poll and let's do it by applause so that the live stream
people can catch it.
How many of you at one time were on the left?
Yeah,
I can be in that too.
Yeah.
And how many of you would say your conservative now?
How many concerns?
Yeah,
I supposed to clap.
still doing the hands.
Okay.
Uh,
how many of you are libertarian?
There's always one loud room cause if few object gallery drives in,
ladies and gentlemen right here.
Uh,
and yeah.
How many of you were objected this,
uh,
how many of you are
progressive?
Do we have any progressive's here?
We're going a little rule and you,
you kind of,
oh,
we got one right here
and you kind of nodded half a little bit or I don't know if you're just shifting
in your seat,
but it's good.
That's great.
I mean,
I would love for progressive to be here and I'd love to take a question from you
maybe at the end.
Um,
so,
all right,
so we have a little oxygen in this space.
I do believe perhaps something has happened where we're starting to win a little
bit.
Um,
I think that there's,
they're lashing out the way they are because they're sort of like a wounded
animal at the end who you're trying to put your hand out there and offer them
something and they only know how to strike back.
So just very quickly,
last night when I was at University of New Hampshire,
there was a one,
you know,
there's,
they're screaming and they're shouting me down and they got their noise makers
and they're repetitive groaning.
I mean,
the,
the chance they're like robots or zombies or whatever.
Uh,
but there was a woman in the back,
uh,
who I had been talking about,
Jordan Peterson,
and we'll put him on the map,
obviously was the bill in Canada,
the,
the Trans Bill that if you mis-gendered somebody you could potentially face a
fine,
which perhaps could,
we could have become a law and then imprisonment and all sorts of things.
And Jordan said,
I have no issue with trans people,
but I don't want the government to be allowed to tell me what I can and cannot
say.
I think most rational people can agree with this.
And I told that story and there was a trans woman in the back and she started
yelling at me and,
and you know,
telling me I don't like trans people and all that.
And I told her that I want her to have the same rights as everyone else and live
with the same dignity as everybody else and,
and hopefully find someone that loves her in life and can find goodness and all
that stuff.
And I said,
is there anything that I just said there that would lead you to believe that I'm
transphobic or a bigot or anything?
And I could see it in her.
She didn't know what to do.
So she basically just yelled that she hated me or something to that effect.
And we have the video of this and maybe we'll release it.
I don't want to make it about her because I think,
you know,
the other guys often are attacking people.
I don't want to attack people,
I want attack ideas,
but I,
but I thought it was a good example of where we're at at the moment,
which is there ain't much left.
But now my question for you is how do you show people that they can get out and
that they can realize that freedom and limited government and free markets and
all of that actually is the answer.
Well first of all,
five say that I just want to support what you say cause I,
I,
I think it's really,
I mean it really is a backlash against these people.
And,
and you can see it,
I think vocally is a great example of this.
Right?
Um,
last year bench,
have you ever tried to speak at Berkeley?
And at Tifo went nuts and everybody went nuts and it was shut down and the
university did nothing this year.
The university said,
no,
we believe in free speech.
We're actually gonna let everybody speak.
I mean,
you'd think they got that earlier,
but you know,
maybe took a few riots and this year bench spoken.
Yeah,
the university,
I spent $600,000 to protect him.
$600,000 so a little orthodox Jew could give a speech.
Do you realize how insane that is?
But in an odd way,
you went to Berkeley and I went to Bennett was,
you know,
and I don't think they spent 600,000 but it was all our security yelling and it
was fine.
But it happened.
And the point is that I think even administrations or some of these universities
are figuring out that maybe the wrong strategy is to just let this run a muck
and,
and that's a good sign.
Um,
how do you do it?
How do you convince people?
And this is the key because the key is to have an alternative to have an
alternative to what the left is offering and they has to be something positive
that you have to inspire people with.
And I think that positive has to be at a personal level,
I think.
I think politics takes care of itself.
I don't think the debate at the end of the day and a challenge at the end of the
day and the discussion at the end of the day needs to be at the political level.
The real question is,
do you as an individual want to be able to make decisions for you?
Do you value your life?
Do you value your life enough to be,
to want to live your life to the fullest and be able to make decisions about who
you sleep with and who you marry and about what kind of business you want to
start and what kind of profession you answer without getting permission,
right?
So once you leave college,
do you get to make decisions for yourself?
Is You'll light valuable enough to be able to you to be able to make those
decisions for yourself?
That is really the key question.
And if the answer is yes,
I want to make decisions for myself,
then everything else follows easily from that.
And yes,
I have the tool to make those decisions.
My mind,
we all have this reasoning capacity.
We all have the tool to make decisions and to live well for ourselves.
Then everything else flows from that.
Then it means that bought out right?
But out of my life,
leave me alone,
which is all basically what we're asking politically is let the government be
there to protect us from people wanting to intervene in our lives with force.
And other than that,
leave us alone because we can take care of ourselves.
So I'm going to make a,
you're on blush here for a second.
I've told this story once or twice.
I think I said it to you,
to your face with last time you did my show.
But he's not just saying this,
this isn't just stuff he's saying.
He's,
he's really telling you something on the human level that is very true.
And I know it because I heard it from him and it changed my life.
So as some of you may know,
we were on aura TV.
Uh,
the Rubin report was on or a TV for awhile after we left the young Turks and the
show.
That's when the show really started blowing up and bigger.
The show got the more that the network wanted from us and some of their failing
shows,
they were kind of letting skate by and I couldn't really understand that.
I thought you need to be giving us more now so that we can expand.
But instead they wanted to take more from us.
And I had never met you before before you had been on my show.
You came in,
we sat for an hour and your own talked about rational self interest and why you
should fight for the things that you believe in and that you shouldn't just give
of yourself endlessly and everything else that you just said.
And we finished that interview.
I walked right into the control room and my team was in there and I said to
them,
guys,
I'm going to leave here and I hope you'll come with me.
And fortunately the guys that I wanted to come with me came with me.
And from that moment of two months later,
we launched independently and my life completely changed and the show has blown
up since then.
And I've used those ideas.
I mean the way that I've even built my business has been with these principles.
So I know that these are real things.
These aren't,
he's not just sitting here saying,
take charge of your life as if as if it's some like,
you know,
Mumbo jumbo.
It's something that's real.
I know.
And I'm saying it because it affected me.
To me,
this is like a thousand times when we pulled in the politics.
I mean,
what's really important is what you as an individual do with your life.
Whether you take responsibility for it,
whether you really understand that you got one shot at this is no,
we play every second you live,
you don't get again.
Right.
Never waste a second.
In that sense,
it's about living life to the fullest and making the most of that life and not
just,
you know,
we're taught from when we're this big that we should sacrifice fathers,
that we should compromise and we should always do what the majority wants.
No,
none of that is true.
All of that is bad advice.
Right?
Break the rules.
I was just with somebody today and he said,
he's giving a commencement address to the high school at Wayne's daughter goes,
and he's,
the theme is go break the rules and he asked me,
which rules would you break
[inaudible] I said,
you know,
that's hard.
I need to think of it as a positive.
I said,
you know,
tools to principles that are the positives,
like live for yourself.
Think for yourself,
and then what rules does that break?
Well,
break them all code that has taught you,
you shouldn't live for yourself,
that your purpose in life is to live to others.
The purpose in life is to sacrifice that.
The noblest thing you can do in life is to sacrifice for others,
right?
No,
live for yourself.
You want to help others,
help others,
but do it because it's good for you because it's good for the world in which you
live in.
Right?
How do you,
how do you think the branding ending here
got so mucked up?
Because I think most people intuitively know this.
I see a lot of you guys nodding and obviously you know who we are,
so we have a somewhat selected crowd here,
but when we talk about this stuff now and eat again,
I mean bringing it back to Connie,
all he did was say to people think and that that has become controversial.
Something happened with the branding and maybe it is all the things that we talk
about,
about academia and that the schools,
and I'm sure you guys are,
are suffering from some of this here,
professors that are,
are indoctrinating you instead of teaching you.
And if you dare say anything that's anything remotely close to small government,
you'll,
you know,
get guff for it.
Last night I had a student or at Umass I had a student who was telling me about
all the anti Trump and Andy conservative stuff that their professor was telling
him about.
I said,
what class is this?
Biology.
Yeah.
Well this is real.
This is real.
This is,
but this is actually real.
So what do you think happened that allowed this to get so confused?
Well,
I mean that assumes that it's some event that happened on different issues.
It's different things that have happened.
So on the issue of living for yourself,
I mean this is a battle we beat fighting for 2000 years.
Really since the Greeks,
right?
Christianity is anti this idea that you should live with yourself.
It's all about sacrifice,
right?
Um,
but the Lakeman got it.
Wait,
the founding fathers of this country did that collision of independence.
It does not say you have a right to sacrifice.
You should work for your community,
give shouty and do community service that's not in the declaration of
independence,
the decoration and dependencies you ever white to your life.
You have a right to your liberty and you have a right in the most self
interested political statement in all of human history.
You have an inalienable right to pursue your happiness,
not some goop happiness.
Right.
All right.
The liberal [inaudible] the lightening.
Got It right.
And,
but since 1900 and I know this was more history and philosophy,
maybe didn't want to hear,
but since 1900 or 1800 there has been an effort primarily by the Germans,
by the way,
by Melien an effort to undercut this too,
to subvert it in the name of tribalism and the name of collectivism in the name
of,
of religion,
in the name of fill in the blank,
but to undercut the achievement of the enlightenment and the tube and other than
lameness,
two ideas,
reason as efficacious as the tool by which we survive and thrive and
individualism.
The idea that the individual is what matters.
Those two ideas of being undercut systematically from con,
from a Hago,
Schopenhauer marks all the way to Nietzsche.
And then of course the moderns if they're taking that up and as the left has
become more and more and more dominant in the university as it has for the last
hundred years.
I mean,
it was bad when I went to school 30 40 years ago.
It's a hundred times worse now,
right?
It's just getting worse and worse as they become more dominant.
Those ideas have become the dominant ideas that everybody talks about.
And now you're supposed to be regimented in your whim,
worship.
You are supposed to have the same emotions.
Yeah.
You know,
you are not allowed to think.
Thinking is,
is,
it's this thing that whites,
males do and it's,
you know,
it's impressive.
Reason is oppressive.
Yeah.
Reason is a it.
Um,
so it really has become a dominant within the culture in which we live dominant
in the world,
which we live in academia.
And this is why I think most Americans feel alienated from academia because they
go,
what do you mean?
Of course I should live for myself at least to some degree.
Right?
Of course.
I,
you know,
I should,
uh,
I should think,
what's this about?
Not Thinking this is stupid,
right?
Uh,
and you're seeing this alienation between,
a lot of Americans didn't go to college and who may be in the middle of the
country or it didn't go to the big really left wing schools and the people who
go to school,
the people who get brain washed by the professor and I brainwashed.
But all they hear is one message.
Uh,
so I think it's turned slowly over,
over,
over a long period of time.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's a turn that's hap.
It's deep,
right?
It's,
it's deep,
full.
It's philosophically deep.
It's not just something in politics.
The change.
Yeah.
It's something about our view of the fundamental nature of reality and of
mankind.
So I want to dive into that a little bit cause we,
we haven't done too much of that together,
but quickly,
I'm curious how many of you actually agree with what I started with that
something maybe has shifted and perhaps we're winning now.
If you'd left,
let's do it by applause again,
Jessica [inaudible]
I really do believe that and,
and that's gonna be the interesting place.
But let's,
let's get to some of that underpinning of this because,
you know,
I,
I talk with,
with so many people who I,
who I admire,
who are great thinkers from Sam Harrison,
Jordan Peterson and Michael Shermer and Steven Pinker,
who you mentioned in the theories of these people.
And there seems to be a debate sort of weather,
whether reason alone is enough of the bedrock to,
to form free societies or whether that has to come from,
as you know,
Shapiro calls it an unmoved mover or from some other belief in something that
basically I had a conversation with Michael Shermer and Dennis Prager on my show
about this,
about God and morality and Dennis's position.
Dennis,
of course,
as a believer,
Dennis's position is that on a micro level,
any of us can be good without God.
That we can,
we can choose good things and be moral,
etc. But that on a macro level,
a society can't without God.
Now obviously my,
uh,
Michael Shermer takes the opposite position,
which is where you are.
Yeah.
Um,
but can you talk about that a little bit?
Sure.
And,
and let me just say before I talk about even that,
that,
that Michael Show him and I are going to disagree about what more reality is.
We're going to agree that you can add morality without God,
but we'll get to disagree about what morality is.
And even this issue or reason,
Sam Harrison,
I might disagree on what we use in is right and what it really means.
So there's a lot of juicy,
interesting philosophical discussions to be had.
Yeah,
I mean you would say,
um,
we do incentives like three,
you guys disagree on free will,
which is what you can't have reason without flew in my view.
So he's talking about reason.
What does even mean if you,
if you're not even making choices,
if it's not you making choices,
if you just an automaton.
So if you disagree,
if you will,
you disagree really about everything.
But that's,
that's to me where the juice is,
where the real interesting discussion is.
And I think what the left the,
the nanny left has done is it's excluded itself from even this debate because it
won't even engaged,
right?
They just yell and scream and shout.
But the interesting debate is happening can happen,
should happen between Jordan Peterson,
between,
uh,
Sam House,
myself,
the Weinsteins.
These are the people who should be having this debate because there's wheel
philosophical issues to be worked out,
right.
To be understood,
to be discovered,
to,
to be,
to be figured out.
It's not simple.
It's not straightforward.
Now,
the idea that morality,
reality is the code by which to live your life by which to make important
decisions in your life.
Right.
To,
to,
to know what is good and what is bad,
what is the white path and what is the wrong lens.
The ideas that is dependent on something written in some ancient book or is
dependent on some person's ability to commune with spirits,
right?
Which is basically what religion demands.
Either you believe in some book or you commune with spirits and get information
directly,
or you have an intermediary who communes with the spirits and get,
but even when I say it,
it sounds so ridiculous.
It's,
it's hard to take seriously.
But
you know,
so,
so if I don't believe in the spirits and I don't believe in this ancient book,
I can't make proper decisions about my own life.
Now Take Dennis Prager's argument that yeah,
you can,
you can.
But as a society we can,
what does that mean?
That means that most of you can't.
It means the most of you are too stupid to take care of yourself.
Most of you are too stupid to understand what right and wrong is what's good for
your life,
what's bad for your life,
what will lead to the horrible consequences,
what will lead to good consequences and therefore we use,
we had to sell you a story about fairies and gremlins and,
and,
and stuff in order for you to be moral in order for you.
And now that to me is absurd.
Morality is about figuring out,
and this is where funnily enough,
Sam House and I,
at least on the approach,
agree,
morality is about looking out at the world and empirically figuring out what is
good for human beings and what is bad,
what leads to flourishing and success.
And what leads to the destruction,
death,
disease and starvation.
Right?
That's what [inaudible] and then do the things that lead to success and avoid
the things that lead to death and destruction,
not that hot right now.
It's a little bit more complicated than that.
It a little harder than that.
But basically that's the,
that's the chore that Your Ethics Department,
if you have philosophy department,
your,
your ethicists.
Should we be thinking about what are they actions,
the values that people should pursue that lead to success in life,
that lead to flushing to happiness to just a,
a sense of what being about the world and what are the actions and sense where
all of the same species.
But most of the time I'll take that.
Yeah.
Most of the time,
um,
you know,
if you eat,
if all of us eat cyanide,
we pretty much all die.
Right?
The sudden we've got a great ending of this show,
by the way,
just stay tuned for that guy.
And they claimed who wrote colts.
I really trying to Max out the youtube views,
you know what I mean?
We have our particular nature.
So just like wave up,
particularly in HR in the material sense it.
So if you take a knife,
you know,
I'm just waiting for Dave.
Yeah,
some things have certain impacts.
The same thing in the spiritual realm.
If I lie all the time,
it has a certain impact on my life.
Not a good one.
So it's pretty easy if you're a kid and experiment a little bit of lying and
test it out a little bit to figure out like not a good strategy in life.
If you want to make friends and make money and be successful.
Only profession in the old universe we lying actually leads to success is,
yeah.
And that's why,
who cares about politics?
Boring,
stupid subject.
But everything.
And I always say,
have you ever met,
have you ever met a happy,
flourishing?
Really a politician who you go,
wow,
what a life this person lives.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
No.
The whole Bush clan looks like miserable,
pathetic human being.
I mean the last,
the last guy who gave you that sense of probably George Washington,
right?
And or I mean,
I can't think of it.
Look at,
look at the Clintons.
I mean they look like they want to slit their wrists.
I mean,
so the,
the,
the idea is let's go out there.
This is what morality should do.
Let's go out there and figure out what leads to human success with two leads to
individual human success and do that.
And that's what morality is.
Morality is not some mystical,
crazy,
strange science that we have to commune with the spirits and or to figure out,
no,
it's an empirical science.
Just like any other sites.
What succeeds?
What fails?
Let's do the stuff to succeed and don't do the stuff that fails.
That's it.
So No,
you,
and,
and succeed means live well and live wall means longterm.
Cause you know,
Ben is going to come in and say,
what about the chicken?
The ball,
you really want the chicken,
the ball,
right?
I mean he did that on your show.
Like,
no,
I don't really want the chicken,
the bar because I know the consequences of the chick at the bar.
So it never,
it never really enters my mind,
right.
Because I love my wife and I want to stay with her.
And this is stupid,
right?
So there is no short term self into short term as a whim.
Worshiping going by your emotion is anti self interest.
It's an type model.
It's a model.
So don't do it.
No.
So no,
I,
I in the flip side is that what is religious morality?
It's whatever somebody's,
you know,
made up,
it's unconnected to reality.
It's nonscientific,
it's made up stuff.
Um,
and it,
it's completely subjective and it means actually nothing.
It's,
it's the least objective morality possible because it's,
it's,
you know,
this is why,
how many sex or Protestants in ism audit?
Like I dunno,
100,
200,000,
right?
Because they don't feel like following that commandment and they go into it,
not something else.
Right.
They start to one sec where you allowed to do that thing,
right?
If you put a 50 rabbis in a room to study a particular paragraph,
how many opinions are going to have on that paragraph?
51 at least.
Yeah.
So you know,
where's the objective nature of morality coming out of this experience?
No.
The only objective morality isn't a morality that is derived from real reality,
from from the world out there scientifically,
right?
It's science.
So what I love about these kinds of
is that all of the people that you just mentioned that we've been talking about,
that I know you guys follow and listen to the podcast and things.
These people are actually friends and,
and,
and truly comrades.
I know a bad word for it,
group of freedom lovers here.
How am I in the best sense of comrade,
but,
but the fact that
these people,
whether it's Dennis or Michael or whoever,
that at the end of the day,
whatever those differences are,
we're actually relishing those differences at the moment.
I mean,
we really are.
And I think that that's what's driving people to us,
that this endless hysteria has now driven people.
I would have never made sense to me.
Well,
but five years ago before I really was doing this version of what I'm doing,
that at all I would be talking about every day is that you should live life
free.
And once,
once that hit me,
once I really had that revelation,
well then it did change a lot of my politics.
And I know you think the politics part are the,
are the boring part of this,
but it led me to now being for free markets and some of those other libertarian
and classical liberal,
cause you know,
I think that's right.
But I think this is the kind of debate that needs to happen,
right?
They kind of philosophically deep debate about these issues that matter and you
can have this debate and still be respectful and totally specked out of sight.
This is not easy stuff.
It's not obvious.
Right?
And,
and it's,
it's interesting and engaging to have the debate and the discussion and I think
that's what you're facilitating what you're facilitating is really the creation
of why this movement is kind of building around Dave Wright is because David's
facilitating a conversation and would,
would,
uh,
would I inventure pure,
we'll have a conversation independent of Dave.
I don't think so.
Right?
I mean there's a certain or Bret Weinstein because we come from things.
So definitely,
but the conversation,
I don't think we're going to convince each other.
I never go into debate thing.
Can we get convinced the other guy never know,
even if,
but you guys are going to benefit immensely from it and,
and uh,
thousands of other people are going to benefit immensely from hearing two
intelligent people who disagree.
Talk about a topic that's important in a respectful,
you know,
rational way the world benefits from it.
Even if we don't,
we're not again,
with,
most of us are too old to,
to,
to really change these,
the,
these ideas and we're two fixing our ways.
But the conversation is fascinating and benefits all of the people who listened
to it.
Yeah.
So that,
that's why I love,
that's why I love coming to colleges.
I mean the fact that you guys care about this stuff is amazing to me.
I mean,
I'm not that much older than you.
I'm a little,
little.
I was in college in [inaudible] 94 to 98.
Um,
I'm 41.
I spent four years in Logan.
Paul,
they won't even bore you guys.
What year are we?
Most of you guys born,
oh go fuck yourself.
This is so great.
This is why I stopped being a professor.
You see,
the thing that sucks most about being a professors,
every year your students get younger [inaudible] you are young Jesus.
Um,
yeah but I spent,
I spent four years in college smoking pot and playing Sega Genesis,
but libertarian,
there's always saying,
I can't tell if you're just applaud everything or the choice things,
but either way.
But the fact that people are at college and coming back
to events like this and thinking about these things,
it's kind of beautiful.
But let,
let's move to a little bit of the political stuff because we were going to talk
about free markets a little bit.
Cause that's one of the things that I definitely have changed.
And you know,
most of my liberal beliefs about living let live and especially on the social
things that,
you know,
gay marriage of course,
and,
and you know,
you should be able to drink whatever you want,
smoke,
whatever you want.
And the rest of that,
that has not shifted.
But I definitely have shifted as I've,
as I've come to this world and had these discussions,
I definitely have shifted.
Right?
I would say economically because I've realized that you should keep more of what
you earn so you can do what you want with it,
whether it's spend it on yourself or donate it to causes that you believe in,
that the government basically is,
especially the federal government is just this monster that is constantly
wanting more and you know,
look how pissed all the Trump people were when he signed this omnibus package
because he came in and said,
we're going to drain the swamp.
And what did he do?
He signed the same old thing that funds planned parenthood and a bunch of other
things that he's based hates.
So the government,
the federal government especially just keeps growing and growing and growing.
I told you about the obscene check that I wrote is living in California.
That's,
that's at the state level of course.
Um,
but I think it's interesting that once you get the ideas of freedom,
it's pretty obvious that it's completely linked to how your economics will
change as well.
It is.
I mean,
at the end of the day you should have the power to make decisions about your
life,
right?
But if you're,
if you're in California and you,
you pour and you're trying to break through,
you know,
you have to spend like 2000 bucks to get a license to shampoo head.
Right?
I mean,
that's insane.
You have to open up,
you have to get a $20,000 government program to open a nail salon.
It because you know,
they all going to be affected with that fungus and we're all gonna,
you know,
it's just the government needs to protect us.
Otherwise,
what will happen in the Nail Salon?
What would you say to them?
People that say that,
well wait a minute.
If we left everything to be unregulated,
that you know,
the Nail Salon would be dumping the stuff in the river and all just all this
sort of hysteria on this,
that the government is the,
is the unit that has to come in and make sure that people aren't killing each
other and infecting each other in a whole bunch of them.
Then it is hysteria that it's nothing more than that.
And it's based on history that is told from an historical perspective.
That's not true history.
The fact is the markets are brilliant and beautiful and regulating themselves.
And can I articulate for you the solution to every one of these problems that
exist in the market?
No,
because the market usually comes up with solutions that I could never imagine.
But the fact is I was,
I've listened,
I listened to NPR,
I admit it.
Wow.
You know,
guilty as charged,
but it,
I'll be up,
er,
when I lived in California,
I'll tell you why I live now in a minute,
but when I lived in California,
was writing those very large checks to the government.
Um,
I,
you still listen to NPR and he used to run these stories about farming and about
food safety because food safety is a big deal in California.
And they used to interview the farmers and without NPR really realizing what
they were doing,
the farmers would basically say,
look,
the the people who come here from the FDA,
we can manage them.
That's not really a problem.
It's those guys from the supermarkets who come and inspect our food.
They're really difficult,
right?
It's really hard to get by them,
So who has an incentive to make sure your food is safe?
Mcdonald's does this supermarket does the restaurant selling you the food does
not.
Some lazy,
Lazy,
whatever bureaucrat who's not going to lose this job if these e coli in the
salad because he's a government employee and can't lose his job.
But believe me,
if that was a private contractor that supervised the salad and it got equally,
they are gonna lose their job,
the restaurant might lose millions of customers and go out of business.
There's real consequences in the real world if something goes wrong.
And people,
sorry.
I often say,
you know,
I walk into the elevators anywhere in the United States and you've got a little
diploma on the wall and it says,
uh,
government supervisor supervise this elevator and it will not fall.
You will not die.
Don't worry.
Because we know,
right?
We know.
All of us know that if not for the government,
elevators would be falling all across America telling.
But we laugh at everybody laughs when I say that,
but we really believe that.
I mean really believe that,
right?
Anybody here who considers himself anything short of a true free market or
believes that because you believe in regulations and all regulations are based
on that assumption,
right?
Mcdonald's the way if you live mcdonalds completely unleashed,
They would basically sell you tainted meat because the best to make monies to
kill your customers.
Now,
I mean,
and the best way to run a nail salon is decreed fungus on the nails or whatever
it is that the danger is and they also,
I mean that is bizarre and that's not to live in the real world with business
people are the most diligent people in the world to try to make sure that the
businesses are safe,
that they,
that they're selling a good product and knows who are not get,
get,
go out of business very quickly and get it eliminated by the marketplace very
quickly.
And Yeah,
the free market is riskier,
is risky or they are risks in a free market.
There is noise in a free market.
It's ups and downs.
In a free market.
In a sense it's riskier than a controlled market,
but the controlled market,
the real risk of a control market is it goes,
no way.
You can't live.
You get told what to do,
what to buy,
what to eat,
what to drink,
how to live.
And if you're,
and this is the thing I ask liberals,
right?
If you don't think other people should have a say in who you sleep with,
then how can other people,
how should other people have a say in what you sell?
Uh,
how,
how is it that other people should,
have you seen how you sell it or what did it makes business different than any
other activity in life that you think should be free?
What is it about money that,
that suddenly other people get a say in how you do your own business and,
and you know,
it is,
it's,
it's the,
the,
the left is,
is fundamentally Marxist there materialists.
So what they really care about what any,
and I see this in debates when I do about inequality,
what they really care about is money.
See,
I don't care that much about money.
They really care about money.
So what they want is their money and they want to redistribute it and they want
to take it and they want to decide where it goes.
They don't care about the spiritual stuff.
They don't care about sex.
I don't care about all that stuff.
That's why you can do whatever you want with that.
You can live your own life there with the right cares about the spiritual stuff
right there.
They come from religion with spiritual is important.
So that's what they want to regulate.
That's what they want to control.
That's what they want to tell you how to live,
but they don't really care about money,
money,
the spiritual,
so they don't really care about money that much so that you could do whatever
the hell you want with.
Right.
So I say no.
I care about both.
I care about the spiritual,
I give out the material and I want to be able to make my own decisions about
both.
And it's none of your business.
If I go bankrupt,
it's none of your business.
If I,
if I commit,
I don't know why we going to suicide today.
I'm on suicide,
suicide watch.
If somebody commits suicide,
it's none of anybody's business.
What I do with my life,
my life is mine.
And then people say,
well,
what about the poor?
And I'm tempted,
right always to say to somebody like that,
why do you care?
Because I really want to know,
why do you care now I care about the poor.
At least I care about some point.
I don't care about all the pillow,
but I want to know why is it that the first response I get from any audience,
what about the poor,
right?
What is it?
What triggers that right?
A,
you assuming the poor can't take care of themselves.
I don't,
I assume they're just as human as anybody else.
They have the capacity of your work.
They have capacity to produce.
Actually,
if you let them free,
they can become anything they want to become.
Right.
Then there are no limitations.
Um,
and,
and in free economies,
the poor rise up and,
and they do very well.
I needed the only place where poor whites up as in free condoms.
Why do you care how many people really can't take care of themselves?
Really can't find a job,
can never do any of that stuff.
How many people?
Yeah,
really can't and let you know cannot and they don't have any family members to
take care of them and they don't have any friends to take care of them.
They really destitute and nobody's there to help them.
How many people like that all day in the world or in America?
I mean how many,
what's the percentage?
Give me a percentage
during
the military.
Does a lot of people on bad,
right?
You made it through.
Yeah.
So I know a lot of people in that 10% of the bottom population,
they can,
they can do stuff.
I can't do I,
you know,
I was watching this guy clean my windows.
We watch watching today at I high rise here in Chicago,
cleaning the window,
sitting there,
cleaning the window.
Right.
You don't need a high Iq for them.
But you know what?
I couldn't do it.
You put me anywhere close to that thing and I'll,
I'll run for our run for the hills despite its apparent death wish today.
Yeah.
Um,
so I,
I disagree with Jordan on that.
The bottom tier and Billy,
I was in the army,
I was in the military and believe me,
these Railey military did not exclude the bottom 10% of the distribution.
I was with them in a tank.
And I know this is real life,
right?
I mean the dumbest I met in these,
in the army,
I met the dumbest people I've ever met in my life.
I mean really,
really low Iq.
But where they decent people absolute could they function?
Absolutely.
Could they function in a,
in a combat?
Absolutely.
So I I that that the fact that the American military can have whatsapp,
they can clean the windows.
You just use the [inaudible].
We'll,
we'll pick it up at the,
I don't know,
but I'm saying that they can clean the windows.
They get plenty of jobs.
There are plenty of jobs for people who can't do what at that level and they do
the jobs.
There are plenty of people with an Iq of under whatever number you want.
I Know People Down Syndrome who beg,
you know who go to work and I'm making a living,
right?
So the percentage of people who truly cannot take care of themselves is under
well on the 1% and then the question to any audiences,
and then now we're talking about that's under 1% now how many of those don't
have family and don't have friends who could take care of them?
That's even smaller percentage.
And then I asked every audience in the world,
how many of you are willing to put a little bit of money into a pot in order to
help that fraction of 1% of people?
Really Tana take care of themselves under any circumstances.
And everybody in the room raises their hand.
So what's the,
what do I need?
Some government bureaucracy with 50,000 different programs employing hundreds of
thousands of people,
institutionalizing people,
convincing people that they can't take care of them.
Yeah.
Well,
let's,
let's sit there for a second because I think this is interesting because even if
the number,
let,
let's say your numbers are off,
let's just say it was 5%,
right,
so I'm more than tripling the numbers that you're talking about that if people
were given back more of their money because we're funding all of these absurdly
ridiculous,
uh,
bureaucratic monstrosities,
if people were given back some of that money,
if you actually care about poor people,
and I do believe that you can ask the question,
well why do you,
but I do believe people want to do good.
But if you had more money in your pocket and you knew that the government was
not going to take care of those people,
then I do think people would give more.
And I,
I also see this with,
you know,
something like planned parenthood,
which in and of itself I don't have a,
a great issue with.
Um,
but there is a certain amount of people in the United States that are against
them providing abortions.
And I get it.
It's a small percentage of what they do.
But if the government was to not fund planned parenthood,
which I wouldn't have a problem with,
wouldn't all of these celebrities that are constantly talking about all the
great things about planned parenthood,
all of these people with money,
if you're not changing the laws,
wouldn't they put more money in?
And this is where,
this is where it does come down to personal responsibility.
You can make the world you want with your own money in your own resources and
skills and volunteering and the rest of it as opposed to just,
I think what it is really,
I think the answer your question,
it's just laziness.
It's,
it's just
just going,
ah,
you know what?
Let them take my money,
do whatever they want.
And they always have money for bombs,
but we don't have money for this.
And I always find people say,
you know,
I would do it,
but those today it wouldn't do it at all.
You know,
wouldn't do it.
And if we have to force them,
because we know it's the right thing to do at some all thing to do.
But is it the right thing?
Is it a moral thing to do?
I mean,
charity is fine,
but charity doesn't define what morality is.
Chatty doesn't define being ball and taking care of the poor is not that.
It's not that important.
It's not going to point to any of you.
It's not that important to me.
Right.
Be Globally.
Because the fact is I could write a big check right now and sent to to Africa
and save a bunch of kids lives.
I know that and I don't because the fact is it's not that important to me and
I'm willing to say that it's not,
and it's not to you.
You're just,
most of you just won't say it.
Right.
Because there's a kid dying every day in,
in,
in Africa that you are not saving.
Right.
Think of it that way.
This is a,
uh,
what's his name?
Peter Singer's.
Peter Singer's a famous philosopher and this is the case he makes,
he makes you should care because you should care about everybody.
I don't care that much about everybody.
I can't.
The closer you are to me,
the more care about you.
The further you are from me,
the less I care about you because I care about myself.
Now again,
I don't to live in a society,
you know,
in my society,
my particular society,
my city or whatever,
where people where I know people are dying because nobody's taking care of them.
So I'm willing to give a little bit of charity to do that a little bit up to a
point,
right?
But there's even another context that I think people have Vaidya
we know the direct correlation between wealth creation and freedom.
I mean,
this is one of the real truism in economics that you cannot dispute,
right?
It's,
it's in Steven Pinker's latest book,
which you should really read because th th th the chapters about how good the
world is,
just amazing and true,
right?
We know.
I mean,
even Steven Peako comes from the left.
We'll say this is because of markets.
There's not because of governor,
this is because of market rate.
So we know the correlation.
Imagine the United States with all the human resources we have in this country.
If we had a flea market in this country,
I can't imagine how rich we would be.
I mean we think we're rich cause we get an iPhone 11 next this year.
Right?
I always been this out,
right.
I always have to write,
cause I think this is the like my center of my universe.
Right.
But if you do the math,
if you just add like 2% of GDP growth over the last 20 years,
what,
how Richard we would be,
we would be a like an iPhone a hundred
no,
I mean it's,
it's hard to imagine if the United States and grown,
I can't show you the exact numbers so I might be off a little bit,
but like 1% GDP less from the beginning of the center of the 20th century until
the end.
We would be today poorer than Mexico.
1% compounded makes a huge difference.
So if we had a free marketing and I'd states and we were growing at 5%,
which I think is conservative in this country,
5% GDP,
we would be so rich.
The issue of the poor would never come up because a,
we could write big checks because we were so rich,
but B,
they will be,
the amount of money we would pay to have our windows cleaned would be high
because we could afford it.
So everybody's standard of living would,
would,
would rise up as it always does.
People talk about rising boats,
they do rise.
People talk about trickle down economics.
I like to call it flood down economics.
It's not trickle right.
Every,
every,
every simple job that's out there is,
is a consequence of an entrepreneur who created it every,
every,
uh,
every time that somebody gets a gets a ways just because capital is being
invested and productivity of Labor has gone up.
It's a flood down.
It's the,
it's the,
the,
the capitalists and the entrepreneurs and the business leaders who create the
jobs that create the economy,
who drive the economy.
So if you set them free,
the amount of wealth we would have,
the amount of prosperity we will be living under is unimaginable to anybody
living today.
What's interesting about this,
I'd like to shift this a little bit to technology,
but I think it's a great segue to that because if you listen to all of the
people right now,
mostly on the left and the,
and the Bernie of people,
you know,
they're talking about this $15 minimum wage.
We also are living in a time when robots are literally replacing humans.
I mean,
I was at the airport in Seattle not too long ago and at the that,
I forget if it's burger king or Mcdonald's instead of people they now have,
and it's just a big iPad.
And I've seen that in some other places.
So the more that we demand these businesses not have capacity over what their
own business decisions are,
the more we're not going to be able to give people decent jobs.
And also the concept,
you know,
it's,
it's so interesting because Bernie,
we'll talk about,
well,
$15 an hour isn't a living wage,
but you don't want that many people to have those jobs.
You've got,
that should be your entry job to go get some other job.
And also it's like,
I know this and this is where my,
my values have collided with my,
my own business is that right now we're,
we're trying to expand the show and we're trying to figure out what we're going
to do.
And I get,
I get hundreds of people offering to work for me for free.
And I don't want,
I don't even want my interns for free.
I mean,
I,
I want to pay people,
but the idea that I would have to pay someone x amount,
now I want to pay my guys more than $15 an hour and we're trying to figure out
all sorts of things.
And we,
by the way,
we pay 100% of my employees health insurance.
If you're looking for another job that I could take care of it.
Um,
but I'm not moving back to California here.
I want to talk a little bit about California too,
but,
but the idea that the government can manage these things that the,
I mean,
Bernie has never created a job.
He's never created anything.
I,
I think he has three or four houses.
He doesn't let poor people live in those houses.
Uh,
you know,
he's made a lot of money.
You off of being a government,
being a senator for 30 years,
who pretty much done nothing.
And if you really include cutting across the aisle and he's really done nothing
but it all sounds good that that was the point that I'm trying to get ultimately
adjust what you said about I don't care about poor people or it sounds it even
to me sitting here,
it doesn't sound good.
Oh,
I know Ben.
Bernie comes in and goes out $15.
Everyone's going to college,
blah,
blah.
And it all kind of makes everyone feel good.
Yeah.
See I say that,
but I care about the poor much more than boody does because I want to create a
system in which the poor an appboy anymore.
Nobody,
nobody should be poor.
If we had a true free market,
nobody would be poor.
Right?
Uh,
and the fact is,
and again,
look at Steven Pinker's book.
The fact is that nobody in America today is poor.
If what poverty means what poor people middle class was a hundred years ago or
what the rich was a hundred years ago.
Rich people had read years ago lived worse off than poor people do today,
right?
We have super computers in our pockets.
Even poor people have super computers in their pockets.
That's stunning.
Right?
But you said something kind of funny before,
right?
Nobody laughed because,
um,
[inaudible] lots of taking people's jobs literally right now.
That's funny because,
well,
let's,
I'll be taking people's jobs to 200 years,
right?
The first sewing machines to people's jobs.
Every single piece of technology that is being introduced over the 200 years has
taken people's jobs.
And what were the consequences?
Fewer or more jobs,
not just a little bit more jobs.
I lot more jobs.
We have a population today of 8 billion people on the planet.
Let's assume that about 2 billion of them actually working in,
in,
uh,
I mean,
not subsistence farming actually working and the grownup,
2 billion people looking in jobs,
what we call jobs,
right?
We're talking about 200 years ago,
the population of the world was less than half a billion.
Almost all of them were subsistence farmers.
There were no jobs.
Ever since.
We've introduced technology,
all that has happened.
All that has happened is we've created more and more and more and more and more
jobs.
We've never had a period over the last 200 years where we got fewer jobs.
There's always more because the population has just exploded over the last,
uh,
over the last 200 years.
And yet everybody has a job.
And indeed the free or the economy is the more jobs there are.
Like the United States in the 19th century was absorbing massive quantities of
immigrants.
And because the capitalism,
technology,
industrialization,
robots create more jobs and they destroy it always,
always.
So I don't,
I don't get what the,
what people are worried about,
about robots.
Now.
Ask me what the jobs are,
the future.
I don't know.
I mean,
I know a few that I would like,
like a push them,
the suits,
the travels with you everywhere.
I'm starting to appreciate this,
uh,
the find your travel schedule.
And I need something like that.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe even you are my personal in the cities.
Yeah.
Talk about that later.
He charges alive,
that expensive.
So these not regulated by the government.
It's the whole freaking thing.
No license,
no license.
You're looking at an unlicensed on the sys up here.
People
were already,
we'll get back to that in a moment.
All right.
So that's,
you know,
we've,
we've already done more than an hour.
We,
it's really fine.
I do want to get to Q and a because I always find that to actually where,
where we can kind of learn the most.
But I quickly want to just bring this back to technology in California because
you escaped California.
You couldn't take it anymore.
I was at Berkeley two weeks ago.
Uh,
I did an event with turning point and we,
uh,
we had dinner out in San Francisco that night and literally driving to Berkeley
from San Francisco.
There are tent cities all over the place.
I mean,
this is,
this is the progressive utopia,
right?
I mean the San Francisco,
this is the lefty and place that they want to model the rest of the country.
After there were 10 cities everywhere.
I saw,
I kid you not.
I saw a guy shooting up in an alley while we were taking a turn.
Um,
when we went to dinner and we were on a nice street,
we went to a steak house,
our car was parked outside,
the car was broken into and they stole my bag.
So there's some junky running around San Francisco in my underwear telling my
jokes cause my comedy,
my comedy notebook was in there.
I can picture some guy who tends to be going on and on about the regressive
left.
And I'm like,
shut the fuck up already.
Um,
oh you,
but you don't have material for a whole show.
No,
I know.
I'm just done this.
He's opening for me next week.
But this was the progressive utopia,
this place.
Oh,
so then,
so then I take a picture,
get this,
I take a picture of the broken glass in the window of the car and I get
literally hundreds of people telling me,
don't you know there is an epidemic in this city about people just punching and
windows and stealing shit.
And then on top of that,
people started telling me,
this is absolutely true.
There is an APP for people in San Francisco to download so that you can find out
where human feces is on the street so that you can avoid those streets when
you're walking.
The dog wants,
they just don't forget the dog go the dog poop that.
Yeah,
we're good.
But literally for human poop and you have to download an APP to do that.
This isn't the progressive utopia.
We're now drugs have run rampant.
I mean Berkeley Berkeley looks like a circus,
but it really does look like,
like a carny show out there.
Always has been.
But looked at
Barclay was the whole home.
Berkeley one at one time was the home of freedom.
I mean it was the home of free speech Oh,
bit bit.
But the people who advocate for free speech and Berkeley didn't,
weren't advocating for freedom.
They were advocating for a particular type of oppression because they were,
they were,
they were the leftist stuff today.
They were the professors who turned the group of students who today are the nuts
into what they are.
So I,
I don't,
I don't have a romantic vision of the free speech movement of the 1960s I mean,
I ran,
wrote extensively about that what was going on on campuses in the 60s and it was
bad.
It was not true freedom.
They didn't understand what the concept of freedom really was.
It was again,
a rejection of reason and rejection of individualism,
rejection of capitalism,
all the DNA of doing whatever we feel like doing right.
Feel like doing it and therefore we should be able to feel like saying whatever
it wasn't,
there wasn't a proper defense of free speech and that's why he lost.
But look,
it's not,
this is the thing nobody learns from experience is a statement for you.
Nobody learns from experience.
Right.
If people actually learn from what works and what doesn't work,
then we would be living in laissez faire.
Capitalist's heaven.
But they don't,
right?
I mean vocalese nothing is competitive in its well.
Venezuela people are starving to death.
Little babies don't get food.
They starved.
Our people have eaten all their pets,
they broken into the zoo's,
they've eaten all the animals in the zoos,
and they just isn't any more food.
And people are literally dying,
right?
Uh,
millions of people have not exited,
vented to all and going into Columbia,
right?
Not exactly a place you want to escape to,
you know,
to find prosperity.
But it's so much richer.
The Venezuela,
right?
And yet this is socialism.
This is always the consequence of socialism.
And yet you've got all these young people want to be socialists and they said,
no,
that isn't the real socialism.
Okay.
So what it shows,
it's never been tried.
The one that they only say every person who's ever said they were trying
socialist created a hell hole.
Right?
So,
so take,
take on the one hand you say that about San Francisco but also what you noticed
in San Francisco.
It's the high rises going up.
I mean it's on it.
I,
you know,
I lived in San Jose,
close to San Francisco,
uh,
20 years ago and it's non identifiable to cities.
Completely changed the whole Saul south of market phenomenon,
skyscrapers,
the construction even here in Chicago,
construction everywhere.
So on the one hand you've got this booming and on the other hand you've got
massive quantities of homeless people because homeless people know that nothing
will happen to them.
They can poop anywhere in San Francisco and there's an APP so nobody cares.
Um,
you know,
in La,
La is another example where they're homeless people every way and why,
and people always wondered why they homeless people.
And,
and because the city of La has guaranteed that they will build housing for all
the homeless people stay,
keep building housing and putting the homeless people in.
And yet they always are more homeless people and they don't understand where do
these homeless people come from?
Well,
I don't know about you guys,
but when somebody is offering free stuff like free housing,
I'm not going to stay homeless in Chicago where it's cold,
I'm going to go somewhere where it's warm and they promise free housing.
So the more they build homes for homeless people,
the Wallace people,
there will be,
that's basic incentives.
This is not hard sophisticated economics.
This is how the world works,
right?
So you know,
California is this country,
the state of complete,
you know,
dramatic extremes.
You know,
I live lived in Orange County,
which is like the most pleasant place to live on the planet.
It's so beautiful.
Big streets,
everybody's basically rich and life is wonderful.
But you go out to the central valley or you go to skid row in la or you see
people as poorly as anywhere in the United States and it's,
that's what you have in,
in,
in California.
And fewer and fewer people in the middle.
You have wealth and you have poverty.
And,
and people in the middle of somehow getting by because they real estate keeps
getting more expensive and nobody can afford to live in San Francisco anymore.
Um,
and you know what?
People blame the fact that there was just a,
an amazing story in the Mercury News,
which is the local newspaper in the bay area.
Who Do they blame for the high cost of living in San Francisco?
Who's to blame Trump?
Who's to blame technology companies because they creating too many jobs.
They're creating too many jobs,
right?
So their pricing out so,
so,
so too many people are coming.
So it's,
it's their fault.
Right?
And of course the last piece fill that lame is local government.
Now turns out that there's an economist and you go there,
the only people to blame a local gum because how building they're not giving
permits then our building high then you know,
so they say there's not enough room to grow.
They build high instead of just office buildings built condos.
They don't build condos in San Francisco.
But why,
why don't they build condos in San Francisco?
Because the people who live in the nice houses don't get our own notes,
not in my backyard,
on in my backyard.
So nobody said don't build high rises even,
you know,
expensive,
high rise.
They just don't want,
the view's blocked.
They don't want whatever.
Right?
So,
no,
but the fault is we creating too many jobs.
It's those greedy capitalists creating too many jobs and creating too much
wealth and creating the iPhone,
whatever.
You know,
that's the problem.
It's,
it's mind boggling.
And this,
this is not hard stuff.
So yeah,
you should be able to look at San Francisco and say,
we don't want that.
You should be able to look at vintage and let's say we don't want that.
You should go be able to go to Hong Kong and say,
Whoa,
what did they do?
Right?
Or,
or,
or go to the United States and look at the 19th century and look at where we
started and where we ended up and go,
Whoa,
I want to be like that.
So this is,
goes back to the moral point I made earlier.
Let's go study what works and what doesn't.
That's true in economics,
that student politics,
it's true in life.
I'm a scientist.
I want to be a scientist.
I want to go on in nature and figure out what works and what doesn't work.
And I want to do what works and I want to avoid what doesn't work.
Not Work in the moment,
but work over over a lifetime.
Right.
And what works is capitalism.
What works with free markets was,
works,
is,
you know,
a certain approach to your own individual life and what doesn't work as
socialism and,
and,
and uh,
focusing on,
uh,
you know,
guilt in taking care of others and,
and,
and all of that.
If you live a good life for yourself.
And if everybody had that attitude or most people had that attitude,
wow.
You know,
whenever it be tried,
it works amazing.
Or we have to do is do it right.
It's just,
just do it.
That's the Nike thing.
Yeah.
Do,
there you go.
[inaudible] right now and really if you want,
know how bananas things have gotten in,
in San Francisco and Silicon Valley.
Peter Thiel is leaving.
He's taking his companies and leaving and he's moving to the freedom,
loving Los Angeles.
Unbelievable.
Think about that.
Really it's going wacky left a slightly less WAC yet,
but in his estimation that that is how crazy that thing has gotten.
I want to mention one other thing and then we'll get to the,
he was,
I moved just a,
we were clear.
I moved to Puerto Rico.
Yeah.
Yes.
I live in Puerto Rico now.
He doesn't just talk about,
not yet.
He's living it.
I'm living it because taxes and Puerto Rico are somewhere around 4% all in
federal,
state,
everything.
Yeah.
[inaudible] a political party in Puerto Rico,
so if you guys move,
yeah.
You know we're going to take the place over.
All right.
Maybe.
Maybe I'll be the mayor of San Juan or something.
You don't vinyl final.
You mentioned Orange County and if you want to talk about a really oppressive
state government.
I the first time I went to Orange County,
I went to a journey concert and I got for smoking weed at a journey concert,
which I thought you had to [inaudible].
So that is what is wrong with government.
All right,
well this has been an absolute pleasure.
Let me talk to the camera for a second because I do believe in capitalism and
all of the good freedom loving stuff that you're on and I have talked about here
and most likely this video has been demonetized by youtube already.
We are on Patrion.
So this live stream right now is,
we're going to air the Q and a on that,
but if you're watching this on tape delay as it were,
what year did I come up with?
That phrase from the Q and a that we're about to do is going to be a patriot
exclusive,
although it'll all be aired live right now.